through ethnic studies what we're seeing
is the institutionalization of
anti-Semitism where there's this idea
that Jews are white therefore Jews are
the oppressor and other these other
people are brown and therefore they're
the oppressed and there's this whole
idea that we' seen unfortunately since
October 7th that anything an oppressed
group of people does to a so-called
oppressor group of people is legitimized
and it's acceptable hi my name is Dr
Brandy chupinsky um I am an education
consultant with the alliance for
constructive ethnic studies and also a
member of the Coalition for for
empowered education what's being
proposed right now um in the state of
California is to require ethnic studies
um as an admissions requirement for the
University of California system so any
student who wants to attend for example
UCLA regardless of where that student is
from actually if the student can be
located in Kansas in order to apply for
admissions to UCLA that student would
have to take uh an ethnic studies course
in their High School um before before
they apply before they'd be eligible to
apply for admissions in into the UC
system right now the The Faculty members
the UC faculty members their committee
that is proposing um making the ethnic
studies and and admissions requirement
to the UC system right now they're
they're um they're kind of held in check
with guard rails that were put in place
with the California's High School uh
graduation requirement for ethnic
studies they're put in place by guard
rils that say for instance that um
certain ideas that are taught in in the
classroom can't um be anti-semitic they
can't discriminate they can't display
political biases all of those things are
guardrails put in place right now so
that students aren't subjected to any
type of discriminatory uh lessons or
materials in in the classroom a way to
kind of get around that has been
proposed by the UC ethnic studies
faculty uh Group which is which is who
which is the group that's behind making
ethnic studies and admissions
requirement and many of those faculty
members have that committee they've come
out in support of a lot of very highly
controversial ideas so the UC ethnic
studies faculty Council issued a
statement after the uh massacre in
Israel by Hamas um the terrorist
organization Hamas they issued a
statement in support of hamas's actions
saying that those the acts of Terror
were actually forms of resistance and
that they stood alongside um what Hamas
and and the Palestinians have done and
are doing so I was not surprised when I
read the the statement issued by the
ethnic studies faculty Council um
because they've been saying um in a
things along those lines for a long time
um it was um a little bit shocking that
they felt very comfortable saying kind
of The Quiet part out loud for all to
see and hear but that's also beneficial
because now we are very aware of exactly
where they stand and why we have to
stand against the proposals that they're
making like making uh their their
radical version of ethnic socities and
admissions requirement if applicants are
required to take a critical or liberated
ethnic studies course in order to apply
to the UC schools what that means is
that the the group of students that come
into the UCS will be much more
homogeneous than we would hope you're
not going to get the Viewpoint diversity
and diversity of thought that you hope
we would see across college campuses
because those are going to be students
who have been trained to look at things
through a very narrow ideological
lens